men don't understand women
and here's why
women are told to not be so demanding or she's called bossy
women are told to not be too loud or she's obnoxious
we're told not to be too much
we're afraid of causing bigger problems by stating our honest opinion
we're people pleasers
we're afraid to be Frank with someone and be honest with them
because we don't wanna hurt their feelings
might be generalizing here
but oftentimes women are raised to be polite and agreeable
that's why what we say doesn't actually mean what it does half the time
and that's why men find it so challenging to understand us
women are not necessarily playing games
we just find it hard to communicate with men
because we have been raised to be that way
afraid of using our voice
you as a man find it challenging to understand a woman
understanding this basic knowledge of a woman will get you so far in life
you further than any other man really
understanding that this is how women are raised
and this is why we're not straightforward
will help you when you want to understand a woman better
I know we often want you to be mind readers
but I'm telling you exactly why we are the way we are
why we're not straightforward
why we're not direct
not to be agreeable and nice
just like men are raised to be tough guys
well women are raised to be nice and agreeable
you don't understand a woman
reflect on this